film theory
films here
[Music]
a few moments later oh wait a minute
you're the dad funny you guys don't look
related uh uh uh what do you mean i i
don't know what you're talking about
just just just stay away from my uh
huh son that was weird seems like there
might be something fishy going on there
oh well
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
you're welcome that song is now stuck in
your head for a week if you want to
understand what it's like to be a parent
it's having songs like this on repeat
for hours at a time over and over again
and of them all none can top baby shark
it is undeniably the most popular song
in the world being youtube's most viewed
video of all time by a massive margin
9.2 billion views billion despacito
that's in a distant second with a mere
7.5 billion the 2016 music video for the
song by pink fong went absolutely viral
and it has crushed view algorithms ever
since which is all kind of funny since
the song baby shark is actually in the
public domain no joke its origins date
back to the early 20th century as a
campfire song used by camp counselors
and the music rights technically aren't
owned by anyone so uh sorry guys film
theory is now rebranding itself as baby
shark theory we're just gonna start
churning out dozens of versions of the
song to the tune of millions of views
hey i gotta catch up to pinkfong's 51
million subscribers somehow speaking of
if you could just uh you know take a big
old bite out of that subscribe button to
help me swim in their wake a little bit
it'd be incredible and our content isn't
quite as quality as a bunch of rehashed
kids songs but if you like having your
childhood shattered on a regular basis
and having cool stories to tell to your
friends that subscribe is gonna be
pretty darn useful just saying anyway
what we're focusing on today isn't the
song but rather the music video made by
ping phong on the surface it looks like
any other music video aimed at young
kids simple animations bright colors
really overacting children but if you
bother to look closer and let's face it
what else am i going to do after
contributing 700 million of those 9
billion views start to notice something
off about this family of sharks i'm
proposing today dear theorists that
daddy shark and mommy shark are not baby
sharks biological parents the whole song
is just one big lie baby shark is
adopted or maybe even something more
sinister is afoot a finn anyway don't
you run away because today's theory is
gonna be a do do do do do do do see i'll
start off by removing the obvious factor
the shark's colors every shark in the
video is a different color which helps
kids distinguish between them daddy
shark is blue mommy shark is pink baby
is yellow you get the idea and in truth
there aren't many sharks in the wild
that come in those colors there is a
blue shark a lemon shark and even a
bronze shark that appears as orange but
i didn't manage to find any green or
pink sharks like grandpa and mommy
therefore i'm not using it as a factor
in my investigation but even without the
colors you can immediately tell that
something is off about the music video
here's a picture of daddy shark mommy
shark and bobby shark bobby shark
bobby shark doo doo doo doo doo
legitimate cousin
black sheep of the family
go away here's a picture of daddy shark
mommy shark and baby shark all side by
side what do you notice is different
about them the areas that stood out to
me were their snouts and coddle fins
that's the tail fin in case you weren't
sure starting with baby shark we see
that he has a smooth connection between
his body and his snout and his cuddle
fin is shaped like a crescent moon with
a smooth connection between the top and
bottom parts now let's take a look at
mommy and daddy shark both of them have
more defined snouts notice the ridge
right there and both of their tails have
prominent breaks in the middle making
two defined sections rather than just
one and those details aren't just
aesthetic they matter when identifying
different shark species two areas that
you can focus on are indeed the snout
and the caudal fin and so the fact that
baby shark has different features than
his parents immediately says that
they're not the same species of shark
but he's a baby he'll change as he grows
up i hear you shout and if they were
humans yeah you'd be right to think that
but sharks aren't like humans when
they're born they basically look how
they're gonna look when they're older
just a lot teenier not like us where our
features develop as we get older
something that high school matpat is
very thankful for but to know for sure
we should probably identify our shark
species and while caudle fins and snout
ridges are certainly part of that
process for this one we have to pull out
the big guns so it's time for everyone's
favorite segment drum roll please
pixel measurements yup today we're going
old school calculating the shark's
actual size in order to prove what
species they really are and to show
definitively that they are not related
if you're unfamiliar with how pixel
measurements work we basically need to
find something in the video that has a
standardized set of dimensions this then
allows us to figure out the equivalent
size for each pixel of the video and
from there use that information to
calculate the size of the objects we
really care about in this case the
sharks and with the baby shark video
finding a standardized unit of measure
starts a bit tricky it's a video
underwater so there's a lot of organic
foliage and sea life nothing really with
a clear and consistent set of
measurements that is until i realized
what the ping phong mascot is wearing at
the start of the video a snorkel and fun
fact snorkels have standardized sizes
according to the european standard en
1972 from 2015 adult snorkels can only
be a max of 380 millimeters or 15 inches
in length for children that number is
smaller only 350 millimeters or 13.8
inches because they have smaller lung
capacity considering the ping phong
character is clearly small and childlike
think it's pretty safe to assume that
this is indeed a child snorkel set so
measuring the length of the snorkel we
get
367.88 pixels and if we divide the real
world length of 350 millimeters by this
pixel measurement we can see that each
pixel is going to be 0.95 millimeters or
roughly .04 inches we can then apply
that measurement on baby shark since we
see both the snorkel and shark in the
same frame in that screenshot baby shark
measures in at 1 252 pixels multiply
that by the length of the pixel and we
wind up with a shark that measures in at
a hundred and eighteen point nine four
centimeters or roughly three feet eleven
inches now that is one big baby there's
only one kind of shark that would give
birth to a baby of that size and that is
the long fin mako shark their babies on
average tend to be between 100 and 120
centimeters or three and a half feet
exactly what we just calculated every
other shark is either born way smaller
or way bigger a great white for example
is born at around 1.5 meters or 5 feet
in length ginormous that's not all the
long fin mako shark also happens to have
a smooth connection from body to snout
as well as a less defined caudal fin
exactly like we see with baby shark's
design so already we're starting to see
some real results of our analysis but
now it's time for the rest of the family
in this screenshot from the video we see
all the sharks together and now that we
have baby sharks length we can use him
as our new ruler to do a whole new set
of calculations you all understand how
it works at this point so no need to
dive into the numbers fast forwarding to
our results mommy shark measures in at
195 centimeters or six feet four and a
half inches and daddy shark is just a
wee bit smaller at 183 centimeters or
just shy a six foot so what does that
tell us well for both mommy and daddy
shark to actually be a mommy and a daddy
they need to have reached sexual
maturity long fin makos like baby shark
reach sexual maturity at just under
eight foot long and yes most resources
seem to measure shark maturity in size
rather than age i know it's a little bit
weird but i guess in the world of sharks
size really does matter so with mommy
and daddy measuring in under those marks
and considering the caudal fin and snout
differences it just doesn't make sense
for them to be makos so if they're not
makos what species of shark are they i
believe they're bull sharks notice the
more defined snout the sharp indent in
their caudal fin they're a perfect match
and so are the sizes did you notice how
mommy shark is bigger than daddy shark
totally normal in the shark world
including with bull sharks which
honestly means that the song is actually
sung out of order biggest jaws should be
coming from mommy shark but anyway back
on track the sizes also work out for
bull shark maturity male bull sharks
reach maturity between one and a half
and two point three meters or five to
seven point four feet while female bull
sharks reach maturity between 1.8 and
2.3 meters or six to seven and a half
feet exactly the ranges that we just
calculated for mom and dad so there you
have it theorists mommy and daddy shark
are bull sharks and baby shark is a long
fin mako you are not
and not only does the science hold up
but it's totally plausible that these
two species of sharks would cross paths
considering that the long fin mako and
bull shark share territories living in
tropical climates near the equator case
closed friends theory confirmed baby
shark does indeed belong to a different
family but why then why would baby shark
be living with a different family than
his birth parents could it be that mommy
and daddy shark killed baby shark's real
parents and adopted him as their own
it's unlikely sharks don't raise their
young male sharks peace out after mating
the female sharks disappear almost
immediately after giving birth which
would leave baby shark alone to fend for
himself almost immediately sharks don't
really do the whole family thing which
explains why baby shark would be alone
but not so much why he's in an actual
family unit with other sharks the fact
that you have this troupe of sharks
grandma and grandpa included swimming
around together is definitely weird so
then why then would they do this well
let's look again at their sizes the
largest one mommy shark is just over six
foot certainly big but not huge now we
normally think of sharks as these apex
predators meaning that they're at the
top of the food chain and yes they do
tend to be but there are still animals
who will attack and feed on them other
sharks like great whites and tiger
sharks and even killer whales are more
than double the size of our baby shark
family and have been known to feed on
smaller sharks if those runts trespass
into their feeding grounds in other
words what i'm trying to get at here is
what if the baby shark family was all
about survival they say there's safety
in numbers after all and this behavior
isn't unheard of among sharks one report
i found spoke of a school of sevengill
sharks working together to hunt large
fur seals and another spoke about how a
group of bull sharks teamed up to muscle
down a tiger shark that was in their
feeding area black nose sharks are also
known to form groups there unfortunately
weren't any reports that i could find
about sharks forming groups with other
species the shark but if they do it to
take on larger sharks and for hunting
it's not unreasonable to believe that it
could be possible in other words what if
the baby shark family this family of
comparative runs in the shark world
formed a family unit so they could
defend against predators take down
bigger prey and maybe even overpower
larger individual sharks i mean clearly
it's worked both grandpa and grandma
have reached a ripe old age mommy and
daddy have reached maturity and they've
even managed to help out a new baby
shark left all alone maybe that is the
real message of the baby shark song it's
not about the dance moves or the catchy
tune or the child actors overacting and
horrendously mismatching their lip syncs
it's that actually family isn't about
who you're biologically related to it's
about the family you choose to have and
the importance of staying together
despite the odds it's about being
stronger together than you are apart
that the sum is greater than any
individual parts and that through it all
family persists i don't have friends i
got family at least until baby shark
grows up and eats everyone you see
there's a problem with this family unit
and the problem is baby shark himself as
we established earlier baby shark is
most likely a long finn mako so right
now he's a small forefoot shark one foot
smaller than the grandparents and nearly
two foot smaller than mommy and daddy
but it's not gonna stay that way for
long sharks as a species never stop
growing all the way up until the day
they die they are growing and growing
but not all sharks grow at the same rate
by the time baby shark is seven he'll
have reached maturity landon at about
245 centimeters or eight foot in length
mommy and daddy at this point will be
close to their fully grown size just
slightly above that but baby shark will
keep growing into his adulthood a long
fin mako can get up to nearly 14 foot
long 417 centimeters much much larger
than his bull shark parents so either
mommy and daddy are gonna have to turn
on their son to kill him before he gets
too big and becomes a threat as sharks
are scientifically known to do or baby
shark is going to keep growing and is
going to end up attacking his smaller
elderly parents either way things do not
end well for the shark family long story
short there's blood in the water and you
know what that means to a shark
but hey it's a theory
and cuts make sure you chop that
subscribe button below for more
mind-blowing theories about all your
favorite childhood movies and videos in
fact click the button you see on screen
right now to learn all about how the
cars in cars aren't actually cars it's
true but to know what they really are
you're gonna have to click that button
i'll see you on the other side